bonsoir ikea minot merci d'être avec
nous on ne pourrait ne jamais être re
confiné c'est en tout cas ce que semble
dire aujourd'hui olivier verrons quelle
est la réaction du médecin que vous êtes
à cette remarque des ministres de la
santé qui souhaitent libérer les
français
je pense que nous sommes confinés
nous avons un couvre-feu à 18 heures il
y a quand même une série de commerces
qui sont fermés et grands centres
commerciaux
chacun d'entre nous est un peu confiné
dans sa tête parce que si nous voulons
respecter l'ensemble des règles de
distanciation sociale l'ensemble des
règles barrière il y a de facto un
confinement et continuer à penser que
nous ne sommes pas confiné c'est une
erreur c'est vraiment un problème de
communication
bien sûr que nous sommes confinés on
pourrait augmenter d'un cran ou on
pourrait réduire d'un cran mais nous
sommes confinés alors une étude révèle
que le variant angles et représentent
désormais 37 % des cas en ile-de-france
un pourcentage plus proche de la réalité
que les 20% entendu est ce que ce degré
de confinement vous semble adéquat pour
maintenir cette stabilité au niveau de
ce variant africains ou inexorablement
il va forcément augmenter et et être de
plus en plus contagieux et étendue tous
ces variants partage certaines mutations
qui leur donne un avantage génétique
tous ces variantes sont entre 30 et 50%
ou arrondir les chiffres plus contagieux
donc il est évident qu ils ont l
avantage génétique et qu'ils sont plus
facilement transmissible même en
respectant l'ensemble des règles de
distanciation sociale et les règles aux
barrières
nous sommes donc exposés à un risque que
l'épidémie que actuellement est vrai
elle est maîtrisée
en fait elle n'est pas maîtrisée c'est
que nous avons accepté socialement qu'il
y ait 20 mille cas par jour et qu'il y
ait entre 250 et 450
et ce par jour nous sommes habitués à
l'équivalent d'un avion qui tendrait
tous les jours et qu'il y aurait entre
250 et 400 décès par jour et je sais oui
justement pardonnez-moi henrique
casalino mais au moment où vous parlez
de ce bilan terrible on apprend à
l'instant que la france a franchi à
l'instant la barre des 80 mille morts
est ce que justement on s'y habitue où
il ya aussi l'autre côté on relativise
par rapport aux 150 mille morts du
cancer chaque année
bien sûr qu'on relativise il vient bien
sûr que c'est dramatique qu'il y ait des
décès du cancer contre le cancer on peut
faire des choses on peut perdre du poids
on peut ne pas fumer
on sait qu'il ya à peu près un tiers des
concerts ne pas boire il ya un tiers des
cancers qui sont évitables dans le cas
de cette maladie il faut se dire aussi
qu'il y à des décès qui étaient
évitables si on avait sérieusement
rigoureusement respecté les règles il y
à un certain nombre de ces décès qui est
évitable
donc aujourd'hui socialement et le
gouvernement et la population nous nous
sommes habitués à un certain nombre de
décès tous les jours un certain nombre
de ces décès sont évitables et il faut
aussi imaginer que nous sommes à 80
milles laisse et qu elle est aujourd'hui
est que si nous continuons à ce rythme
là nous allons faire probablement plus
de décès en 2021 compte 2020
c'est quand même extrêmement inquiétant
est le troisième élément qui doit
rentrer en ligne de compte c'est que
notre système de santé et tout c'est un
bon même si aujourd'hui en moyenne en
france tous les lits de réanimation ne
sont pas occupés il existe une tension
très forte et le danger c'est que une
poussée épidémique rapide liés aux
nouveaux variants nous mettre dans une
situation de très grand pénurie de lits
d'incapacité du système de soins a
affronté une augmentation très rapide de
la demande de lits d'hospitalisation et
de lits de réanimation et que nous ayons
comme nous le voyons dans d'autres pays
des choix à faire des passions
comprendra des patients comprendra pas
des passions qui pourraient mourir faute
de soins
que ce soit les passions qu vide ou même
des patients n'ont commis de passion du
cancer des patients qui ont des
accidents de la route et qui pourraient
ne pas avoir longtemps ne pas bénéficier
du taux pas qui est le leur 2 le pouvoir
bénéficier lundi dans l'hôpital c'est ça
notre grande inquiétude
je comprends le crainte des hommes
politiques
la première liberté et quand même d'être
en santé
la première liberté et complète de
pouvoir avoir accès à un système de
santé si je dois mourir parce que c'est
un impondérable
bien sûr nous nous soumettons tous c'est
la loi de la vie mais mourir parce que
le système de santé n'a pas pu nous
accueillir ça se saurait impardonnable
merci beaucoup henrique casalino chef
des urgences de l'hôpital bichat paris
merci d'avoir été en direct avec
monstres rt france